このちゃん年末電車ちょっといろいろしてて実況に変わりませんでした
肇社長です
まバー
まぁちょっとねじいちゃんバンドにはいたいんですけどもなかなか帰れなかったんです
けどもそんな僕にちょっとまぁみんカラ届きました
コラボラーメンを色でよく5食分入っててスープが付いてるとエバケンのかラーメンと
いうものらしいです
このガザがメッセーという入ってる理由を誤植ラーメンですね今同じようなので一緒に
作れます年越しそばにどうぞ
月あり方とし声
ちょっとグリそこじゃないラーメンや年末も寂しいだろうと思ってこういうのって
くれるとこでも感謝感謝ですよあやまけんのラーメンは音色がねすごいカラフルみたい
な話を聞いたことあります誤植ですね白黄色緑赤茶色くのブームっていうかやっぱ凄い
らしいねって言うんだけどラーメンはね実感沿いラーメン手で夢と嬉しいねーわー
こんな感じになっておりますちょっとでこういうのを見ると研磨
帰りたくなるはピョンすげーという感じでごショップラーメンが入っております今日は
ただよるバー空洞です
富山下に帰れないそんな数よりにマミーが届けてくれたらん
ラーメンくっさー大事なのはここから俺が本当にラーメンが作れると動画ですね
ちょっと適当にやってみようと思いますまずは勝手な作り方が感じる女が沸騰した
たっぷりのお湯で大好みにより約ニュースがクリっわっっにロスんですよね
ok 茹でるグライダーの黒人できるよこれで揺れる茹でたらどうするんだろ茹でたと
いうことだぞは中国は
面フット者たっぷりのお湯でお好みにより役に風化た3分ゆでてくださいドンにえっぷ
のスープを入れ熱湯300見るとするってラビする方法を大
難しい中なラーメンを見つつ創る会ちょっと作るということは容器が居つつ
一対パっていつつもあるかなああんなの買ってやった123よ通ってもいいかなー
なんて香津興作れるラーメンぐらいラーメンってこんな沸騰してるわー
中根こういう感じでしか入ってないから結構シンプルな名誉せず打ち込めます
これは誰でも作れるんじゃねぇああ
ふうに3分野だけ照明は全部同じなのでまとめて名誉行っちゃっていいってことで麺が
全部同じだから一緒に混ぜてもいいってことだけど一個れちゃったって同署や深く
考える簡単なものが僕は猫舌だった
ラフトって何でしょうねどうしてるか集まったらフッと政府としているまずどこ行っ
たけバック説明書が入ってるんだよって言うなと言ってきまおってだ
麺をゆでるだったらしっかりお湯を切り芸分スイープを入れ等300ミリリットルと
言ってラーメンスープを準備します
熱湯がいる
しっかりお湯を切ってこっち現
ああああああ
履いて外で打ち5速のラーメンできましたーー
寂しいねいただきます
まあグラップラーメンは富山でもかなり有名なんでで食べたことがあるんですけども
未満1ブラックラーメン本当に
ああああああ
別にグリーンいきますはてます本当にグリーンラーメンとか
稲毛ますぞ
ジャンクないよてんだようーん
次ネットはこれまで結構ねぇもっとえずに劣等なんですよ
あからん
ああああああ
次ちょっとホワイトいただきますいただきます
あー不明踏まえけど汗がー
あの実はブラウン金一番美味しいと思ってる俺はよく見る色だもんいただきます
ああああああ
うんんじゃんん
すーっクリーはとどうかって皿減ってなんでなんとかここまで来たんですけども僕は
どうで本日の本題に移りたいこの後族のラーメンを混ぜと何色になってどんなちー
なんか譜面平らげよ
あたきまー汎用グリーンいきますはい
ホワイトでそれを戻して欲しいなぁ怖いとか入ります
ブラウン入ります
おっ
問題の味ですよ味いただきますよくわかんない
いっ
マッハワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワンワン